[Music]
Thanks for coming. Thanks for having me
here. Um I'm Tongima. I'm um I was uh
the CEO and co-founder for HAI. We just
recently got acquired by MongoDB. I'm
also teaching at Stanford as well. So um
this is about rag which is the main
focus of forage AI uh the startup who is
focusing on how to make retrieval
better. So um um but I will just
generally talk about you know rag and
and we'll touch on some of the products
we make as well very quickly. So I guess
why we are uh doing rag or anything like
that right. So I guess the main reason
is that large language model or these
days agent u which are you know using
large language models as well uh if they
out of the box they cannot just uh uh
have priority information from any of
the companies right because if they know
anything about what MongoDB for example
internally has then the the data was
leaked. So that means that if you want
to apply any of this to enterprise uh uh
then um uh you need to ingest a lot of
data from the uh proprietary
information. So um and I'm going to
discuss you know while which kind of
technologies to to enable us to ingest
the data. I guess there are a few
options raet tuning and long context
which are always to ingest data and I'll
focus on raich for the rest of the talk.
So I guess you know for this audience
probably most people knows these
technologies and they are all very
simple on a high level. So for a long
context it's just the most simple you
just dump all your documents uh to a
large language models context and maybe
it's like 1 million tokens maybe it's 1
billion tokens um so and then you have a
query and you just get a response. Uh
fine tuning is like you first find large
model you update the parameters and then
you say I'm not going to look at the
documents anymore. uh when the query
comes I just use the updated parameters
to generate response. Uh and rag is uh
um also pretty simple. So basically what
happens is that on the fly you use the
query to retrieve some subset of the
documents. You use a retrieval of search
method u um and then you get some
relevant documents you give this small
set of relevant documents to the large
language model and then you generate
response based on those contexts. So
this is one my one slide kind of like a
uh summary of you know how I think about
the differences between these
technologies. You know some of the these
are uh uh inspired by some of the
research at Stanford when we kind of
started to uh uh um uh uh build voyage
you know we kind of like believe in rag
and one of the reason is that we don't
believe that fine tuning can work and
and long context I think um um I also
don't really believe that it can be
costefficient in the long run. So, so
basically I think the way that I think
about this is that um I uh try to make
analogy to how humans uh are uh learning
from or using the additional party
information. Um um so in some sense long
context is kind of like you scan an
entire library to answer any single
question right every time you answer a
question you you need to go through the
entire library which has like probably
one billion tokens and fine-tune is kind
of like you read this library in in
advance you muscle memorize them you try
to internalize them in your brain in
your neurons in your synapsis and you
update your brain basically rewire your
brain so that you really know all of
those deeply um the challenge there is
that you know it's very difficult and um
somewhat unnecessary um um because you
know you cannot really memorize all the
books in your in the in the world and
and and memorizing a subset of them
sometimes is kind of like you know which
subset you want to memorize is kind of
uh tricky as well. So and another thing
is that um um it makes you know
forgetting the knowledge also tricky
because you don't know which part of the
knowledge you should forget and how to
cleanly forget all of them and also this
makes the the access the the the data
governance also kind of tricky because
you know maybe there are so many
libraries so many books in a library and
not everyone can access everything and
how to organize those and on the other
hand rag is very very simple and
modularized
uh as I've shown so um and very reliable
and you know and and also kind of fast
and and cheap. So um and it's kind of
like similar to how humans actually are
using the libraries, right? You retrieve
the most relevant, you know, book
chapters or books or book chapters and
then answer the question. It's kind of a
hierarchical way to store your
information, right? You don't really put
all of information in your brain. You
put them in a library and then use them
uh when you need it. So um that's why I
believe in rag and and this is kind of
how you implement the retrieval part. So
basically there's a breakdown of two
components actually there are three you
know if you are advanced so uh so this
embedded models which vectorize the the
documents and query uh into vectors and
the vectors are representations of the
uh this kind of like representations of
the content or the meanings of u the
documents and queries and then use a
vector database to store the data and
also search uh uh with a kaneous
neighbor search in a vector space and
then you get the relevant documents and
then you can use large language model
generate answers. So um we have seen
significant improvements over the
retrieval accuracy in the last two
years. Um when we started voyage you
know I think open I v3 was not uh yet
launched open v3 was launched 1.5 years
ago. Um and in the last 1.5 years you
know voyage you know u has made
significant progress you know coher also
made some progress. So and we can see
that the new model has much better uh
accuracy and with lower cost uh um and
generally we have much better scaling
law right. So the same number of
parameters the the quality becomes
better or the same quality the the the
the parameters becomes smaller and it
becomes cheaper. Um and all of these are
through kind of like you know optimizing
the research stack uh the training stack
you know as much as possible you know
all the way from like data curations
data selection uh uh uh architecture
loss functions you know evaluation so on
and so forth uh and we still you know
believe that there's a big headroom here
because you know right now you can see
that in this plot you know we are
averaging over about a 100 data sets and
accuracy is about 80%. So that means
that you still have like probably 20% of
the improvement um headroom. But that
said, you know, just to be clear, it's
not like for every data set, you only
have 80% accuracy. For probably half of
the data sets, the accuracy is probably
90% or even 95%. And for some of the
other ones, it's kind of 60, sometimes
20, sometimes 30. So that's why in
average is 80%. Um so for so basically
I'm saying like for some of the tasks
that are common uh I think you can get
already very high accuracy in the
retrieval step. Um and another thing
that uh voyage and other uh uh uh
companies has uh uh offered is this
so-called matashka learning and also
quantization of wire tuning. So
basically these are two approaches to
reduce the the storage cost uh for the
vectors. So basically matroscal learning
means that you make sure that uh even
you have like a high dimensional
embedding right you can use a subset of
the uh the coordinates uh is is usually
the first let's say suppose you have a
20 48 dimensional vectors and the first
256 dimensional uh sub uh vector is
still a reasonable embedding the
accuracy wouldn't be as high as two uh
2048 but it will be almost the same u
maybe with like one or 2% loss and
quantization is kind of this in a
similar vein. So where you are even you
lower your precision of the vectors you
still get pretty high performance. Uh
and you can see the uh the trade-off on
the right of the figure uh here. So
basically you can save you know 100x you
know at least 10x without losing much.
If you save a 100x in the storage cost
then you start to lose probably 5 to
10%. Um but voyage you know is doing a
great job here because you know you can
save uh 100x but still doing better than
open eye that's just because the
parental frontier is uh different. So um
um and and you can actually see better
tradeoff you know for domain specific
models which I I'm going to discuss in a
moment. Um I have nine minutes here so I
will probably just quickly go through
some of the uh uh the techniques that
you can use. Um so basically the next
question is that how do you do better
rag you know without besides using
better embedding models using better
embedding models is probably one of the
simplest way um so I'm just going to go
through it quickly so one of them is to
use hybrid search and reankers you can
use you know lexical search and other
kind of search and then combine them
with a reancher uh and voyage provides a
revanker as well um and another one is
you can enhance the queries and
documents by the so-called query deco
composition and and document enrichment
um so this is probably the most common
one maybe spend one minute on it. So
it's actually very simple. You just say
if you have a query rag then you try to
improve the query by uh making it longer
using a large language model. Uh you can
also decompose the longer query to small
subqueries so that you can have like a
few different queries and search for
different subset of documents. Um and
you can also enrich the document by
adding additional ma information in it.
You can add titles you know hiders you
know categories authors dates. Sometimes
you trunk the document so that in the
trunk you don't even have this
information anymore. So that's why you
have to add the global information into
each of the trunks and some of this
global information can be added by large
language models. Anthropopic wrote a
blog post which does achieve pretty good
results. So basically they use large
models to generate additional context um
that you can add to the trunks so that
you can make the trunks you know more uh
informative and then the it's easier to
search uh through them. So um another
one is you can use domain specific
embeddings where um you um you customize
embeddings for certain kind of domains
you know in MongoDB or voyage we
customize it for code for example and
you can see that you know you get much
better performance and also uh it's a
better trade-off in terms of the the
storage cost and the um uh and and
accuracy. So basically you don't lose as
much if you compress the vectors even
further. Um so so here we lose probably
5% by compressing uh for like a about
100x but before we lose probably 10% or
15%.
Um fine-tuning is another one. You can
finetune embedding models with your own
data. Um and you can also use other um
sometimes I call them tricks on top of
the embeddings, right? So these are
different type type of ways to retrieve
um uh using additional information like
graph, you know, iterative retrieval, so
forth. They're all based on embeddings.
Um but uh you can uh use the embeddings
in many different ways as add an
additional layer. Um so um I guess I'll
use the next probably five minutes to
discuss some of the uh and the uh my
vision for how rack will go in the
future. I do believe that rag will be
there forever because this is as I
argued in the first slides uh the first
set of slides. This is the kind of like
very similar to how humans are uh using
uh additional large amount of data. You
retrieve you hierarchically select some
subset and then you use those uh to uh
uh to to answer the questions. I I'll or
take some actions and this is very
efficient because you only use a small
subset of the data. Um and um and as a
um regarding uh how um how regular
evolve from a technical point of view u
I like to draw some analogy u on uh um
from uh how the the AI generally is
evolving. So I think I was reflecting on
when I was teaching at Stanford you know
started to teach at Stanford about seven
years ago. I started to teach with Chris
Ray on this machine learning course and
one of the slides literally have this
seven steps on how do we build ML
systems in enterprises. Um so this
actually this slides is still in the the
lecture notes. Uh we still teach them
but just with more kind of like uh uh
asterisks uh around it. So you can see
like you you need to go through you know
many steps you know collecting data you
know tin test split you know define your
loss functions you know build models and
iterate and repeat and then uh for the
large language model world it's kind of
like this right you don't do need to do
any of this you just take a large
language model out of the box and just
uh you know you can deploy it in
enterprise in most of the cases of
course it's not going to be perfect but
this is already better than in the old
days you do all of these steps in the
enterprise using all the enterprise data
just out of the box you are doing
already very very well. Of course, you
still have this issue that you cannot
the out of the box art model cannot um
uh access proprietary information then
you can use rag uh for it. So, but I
think the point here is that before uh
all of these steps have to be done by
the kind of like the users or the
enterprise or the customers in some
sense. Um uh and now uh you largely
speaking just can take off the shelf
components and connect them and build
your uh AI applications very fast
without going through these training
steps. The trainings still have to be
done, right? All of these steps still
are done uh um but they are done by open
anthropic or voyage MongoDB u the
providers of the models but not the uh
uh the the users um uh the end users.
So um and I think for rag I I would say
probably the same kind of evolution
should happen um um um um so right now
what happens is that u we have the
several different layers where you have
the computing infrastructure layer about
the GPUs you know or some of the KN on
the CPUs and there's also a model layer
where you have the embedding models the
revampers the large language models and
then on top of all of this um people use
a lot of like I call it tricks to make
rack uh accuracy much better right you
can uh uh use all kind of parsing
strategies, you can use all kind of
trunking strategies, you know, uh uh
that the the the the um you can do some
recursive search, you can do some
contextual trunks, graph racks, so and
so forth, right? That's what happens
right now. And it's kind of necessary.
These tricks are somewhat necessary
because the embeddings and reankers and
large language models, none of them are
perfect yet, right? So um and but I do
believe that in the future I think this
model layer will grow uh uh and the
tricks will be smaller. So it's going to
be fewer and fewer tricks and the models
can capture many of the uh the the
performance gain u by the tricks. I
think we have seen this in the large
language model space as well. Right? So
like um two years ago I think you need
to do a lot of things on top of the GPD3
to make your application work and now
even after uh uh out of the box you can
get the same performance as before with
all of the tricks. Um of of course you
still probably need some kind of tricks
because some information are not u uh u
uh uh uh some information um the
embedding models and rankers don't have
just right. So the the the general
purpose models or off-the-shelf models
don't have certain information and then
you can incorporate those uh into your
tricks. For example, one thing that uh
is that you know the definition of the
similarity matrix uh could be something
that you should customize in your prompt
and um in this one you know um I think u
there are several things that we are
developing towards this vision right so
one of them is multimodel embedding this
is to dramatically simplify the workflow
so that you don't have to do many things
right so these days the multimodel
embedding provided by voyage can just
take in screenshots right before you
take a PDF you have to do the data
extraction to turn them into image and
text and then probably do some
embeddings for the image and embedding
for the text separately. um and and and
parsing this PDF is actually complex you
know and for videos you have to do turn
them into transcript um um and then use
the text embedding so and so forth right
right now uh right now we have the
multimodel embedding which just takes in
screenshot you can deal with PT PDF you
know ppt uh uh powerpoint you know any
of the other kind of slice deck in the
same way just take a screenshot and then
use the multimodel embedding we don't
have the uh we can even do the uh same
thing for video not necessarily the
perfect way but like you just take
screenshots of the frames you know
consecutive frames and you give it to
the multimodel embedding and you can uh
turn them into vectors and you can
search over uh those documents or or
videos or slice stack. So um
oops and these are some performance
metrics that we have evaluated you know
we have tried kind of like oh by the way
another one applications tables right
now you can just take a screenshot of
the tables you don't have to think too
much about what is the header what is
the row so and so forth and we have done
evaluations on many of these document
screenshot you know table figures and
and also text only and you can see that
it's u improving across the board so um
the the final one I would like to
mention which is something that we're
going to launch uh soon is that this
context where and auto trunking
embedding. So uh right now what happens
is that when you have a long document
you do have to trunk the data. Um u one
of the reason is that the the context
length of the embeddings is limited and
if you have like a 100k tokens you do
have to trunk into three or four trunks.
You know even though voyage AI has the
probably I think it we have the longest
context window is still like 32k. So
that's one reason to trunk. And another
reason to trunk is that sometimes it's a
long the long document even you don't
trunk. Suppose you can have a way to uh
uh put all of them in a context window.
Still when you retrieve you're going to
retrieve on a document level then you
retrieve a very very long document and
then you should give this long document
to large model. It's going to be very
very expensive. Right? If you give 100k
uh tokens to large model every time you
answer any question if you do some cost
analysis you'll find that that core is
very very expensive. So that's why you
do have to work on a smaller unit so
that you can cut the cost and and be
also more focused, right? So sometimes
you give a long document to large
English model, it misses some of some of
the context in the middle and you have
to use the retrieval to focus on a
paragraph, a page, so on and so forth.
So so that's what happens right now with
the trunking and but all of these are
done by the users. Uh and our vision is
that we're going to do this for you and
also we're going to get all the meta
information about from other trunks. So
basically um uh in a nutshell the the
the the interface will be that you give
us a long document and we're going to
trunk it for you and then also we return
the trunks and also the vectors for each
of the trunk and each of these vector is
not only representing that trunk but
also representing some of the global uh
m information from other trunks. So it
has all the details uh of the
corresponding trunk and also has some
kind of like cross information from
other trunks. So they can get the best
of the both worlds. Um and uh that's
what I'm going to launch you know soon.
And another one is that we're going to
have some fine tune API some point uh to
make you uh uh uh so that you can
fine-tune with your own data. Um I guess
uh it's exactly time. Thanks very much.
[Music]